forty-five-year-old michael dunn he's
being charged with shooting and killing
17 year old jordan davis the
confrontation began over loud music was
there music playing in the car yes what
type of music rather
Lucy how was it for you to be at the
premiere of this film and Sundance and
see and after everything bin you see the
trial there it's really very surreal to
see everything that we had gone through
from beginning to end really brought to
life once on the scream of course there
were nuances about the film and there
were things that happened in our lives
at that time that I had kind of
forgotten or maybe even really wanted to
block out and so to have that posed in
front of you there and you're having to
relive those things and remember those
things it is very painful to watch but
at the same time though it's also
necessary I think that the community the
Jacksonville community initially just
fell in love with Jordan and then for
Michael Dunn to be from out of town he
wasn't a Jacksonville native citizen
whatever they felt that somebody came
into their city into their town and
killed one of their own and then left
and trying to get away with it so the
whole town was enjoying the corner from
the beginning and I just felt that in my
heart that it was great to have so many
people caring for your child what
attracted you to
this I was interested in what you could
say what a large thing you could say
about a something that happened in such
a short amount of time so in these three
and a half minutes I saw this perfect
storm of racial profiling access to
garments and then these laws they're
giving the confidence to use those guns
I have to be so close to the justice
system what are your thoughts on it was
so apparent and evident that Michael
Dunn was in the wrong and why is it the
justice system working the way that it
is supposed to work why do we have to
fight why do we have to stand here and
and are you over the law working the way
that it's supposed to work that was very
was I was very disillusioned by that
very disillusioned by that because that
seems to be systemically what's
happening for minorities around the
country the laws are not working for us
had Michael Dunn been smart enough after
the first shots if he had been smart to
sit in his car dial nine-one-one
he wasn't got away with this guy not
because he the main thing was that they
said you didn't down 9-1-1 then you saw
the police across the street then you
didn't stop for the police you did
everything to get away because you knew
you were guilty had you set in the car
claimed your innocence waiting for the
police to come and make a statement
Michael don't be at home right now I
guarantee you that soon after Browns
death the hashtag if they gun me down
went viral with folks slamming the
mainstream media stereotypical and
predictable